Well if you tried to ask me,
you know what happened when you and this
girl making out in the back seat of a
car 35 years ago. Good luck. I
don't know if this is a few moments.
I remember it. I don't know. It was
girl blooming and it was amazing.
I don't fucking,
don't have to remember like very few
sexual encounters from high school,
but I remember my girlfriend, but
I know that was consensual. Yes,
they're all central,
but my girlfriend gave me a blowjob
on the porch and I came so hard.
My ears rang and it's never happened.
Never happened since.
Peaked when I was 16 years old.
I know. It's so hard. It was like
the best way I can. Literally Mike, you
remember wasn't blow job you've ever had.
I wasn't beating off back then. I was,
I actually had sex before. Jerked off.
Shut the fuck up. Yeah, I did and it's
not like I had sex really young either.
How old were you when you,
when you first thought,
I think I was 16 how old were
you, Jamie? Nine you fuck machine.
He's an animal. Look at, I'm looking
at nutcase. Got Cancer. Next shirt.
Not King
in Catholic school. Just lifting up
skirts and just send it at home. Oh,
Joni over at Saint Peter's.
That's right. Hey, no,
seriously. How old were you?
Do you know? 1717 that's right.
That's the average ages,
man with biggest
guys balls. That's the real nutcase. Poor
bastard. This is a lunch of those guys.
They get elephant Titus of the balls.
I guess they just don't want
to get their balls cut off.
That looks like a Halloween costume. That
was a Perry I said, I was going to say,
but there's some, some men who really do
have those, but we'll get to that guy.
That guy's naked. That's a sac. What it,
I so telling me you fucked before you've
ever joked on yeah, I did. Yeah. And, and,
and, and, and, and so then when
you jerked off, I don't recommend,
cause I had zero controllers.
We stuck in envelope.
I mean I've, I've, I, the first time I
had texts, uh, without, without like raw,
without a condom was, was my
brain was like, all right,
there's a strategy to this.
You gotta be able to last look out the
window. The moment it was just like, yeah,
the first time I ever orgasm was
a girl jerking me off. Fuck yeah.
Well I guess mine was Jean's rubbing
mine was a dry humping. Jamie,
you did a bunch of that shit.
You Dry Hump.
I'm not from dry up and I probably had
like a little bit my underwear, you know,
like I used to have a bit about that.
Like,
like do you ever take your underwear
off and there's a stream of sperm that
somehow or other from the tip
of your Dick to your underwear?
Like what the fuck is this?
I go,
that's those green berets sperm to live
around the tip of your Dick with a knife
in their mouth that don't give a
fuck about your plans for the future.
Those are the ones that get people
pregnant cause they just ready to go,
let's go bowling at the underwear.
Fuck this is pussy. Let's go there.
Over zealous,
zealous,
they hit that underwear because sometimes
you find pre cum in your underwear.
You're like, what is this? Oh
yeah. What's happening here?
Pretty calm is the strongest com
that is the, that is the most potent,
most potent savages like the hordes,
barbarian hordes,
fucking swords and shit. Pre-Cum
is like the good, the what is it?
The green berets or whatever like
that. That's what I said. Yeah.
Then the Greenbury flights because my
regular comments like the navy reserves.
Yeah, like Coast Guard.
They might come out,
you guys going to make it? Not The
disrespect that coast. God, I'm blank.
You boys. Women. Yeah man.
I mean I didn't get any birds
and the bees talk. Did you? What?
Not even remotely the fuck giant parents.
No fucking way to get anything.
I was trying to think. I don't think
they even really did it in school.
Maybe it's just like
teachers. No Man, that shit.
Do you want to know what I got? You
want to have a fucking, this is my,
this is my father.
Embarrass the shit out of me.
I don't know if I've
told this on this thing,
but the most embarrassing
thing my father did to me,
we were eating dinner when I first started
jerking off and figuring it out and
shit. You know, my dad at dinner
in front of my home, my family,
my dad was like, you've been spending
a lot of time in the bathroom.
And my mom was like, Hey, stop it.
And I was like, these motherfuckers
have been talking about me.
They know I'm jerking off. And they've
had multiple conversations like, no,
it must be whacking off again, that
little fucking horn ball, because I would,
I would lock the door and go in the,
I would jerk on the best.
I got a stomach ache and my mother ever
sent him, embarrass you, you, Oh my God.
In front of my fucking, it's like my
sister's there. I was like, oh my God.
And my mom was like, hey, like that. And
my dad was like, oh no, no, no, nothing,
nothing. And I just knew it was him taking
it. You know what it was now as a man,
like I know that to my son,
I'll take a shot like that too.
It was just a guy shooting like
you would tell your son. I know,
but I would shit on them a little bit
too. Cause that was funny. It was funny.
It was very funny in retrospect.
It was like,
like he bought me a Kathy Ireland poster.
Do you remember Kathy Ireland?
He bought me a Kathy other poster
and he was like, don't eat.
And he said something
along the lines of like, a,
don't let this get stuck together.
And I was like, Ooh, but I know he's,
he's just like, yeah,
you'll fucking jerk off.